on new year's eve i
made a little joke on on my story you
know i finally received my gifts
for being the seventh best podcast
i saw that how'd you like the balancing
rocks um they tasted so good man
yeah dude they're man the long one
yeah i'm not gonna tell you what i did
with that one but i couldn't get through
it in one sitting but
you know i ate as many as i could i got
through it in one sitting
yeah okay if you know what i'm saying
hey tick tock this is how you manipulate
the algorithm
so i uh can i just say real quick that i
did balance them and i did actually
enjoy it
um they're just a bunch of like weird
rocks that you're supposed to just put
on it's like uh
what are they what are they [ __ ]
called in canada you make them out of
actual rocks
native american thing isn't it i've
[ __ ] goddamn what's it called i don't
know they're all over the place in the
mountains you just stack rocks on top of
each other
and um that's what it reminded me of it
was actually kind of a little bit zen
stacking the rocks like that yeah i was
making fun of it and then i said it
i set them up and i was like oh this is
kind of fun and then i took them back
down and i put them up another way
and then before i knew it five hours had
passed
of me just balancing rocks and it was
actually
very meditative nice yeah sorry keep
going
no um i was about to go on a tangent but
i'll hold it so
i made a little joke on my story and i
was unboxing my gifts and i said
david you know i'm curious to know what
you gifts
what gifts you received as you know
being the seventh best podcast what did
you what would spotify send you
you know i want to see if they maybe
sent you something better something
worse
and uh she tagged us in her story and
she presented those gifts and she's like
they're right here
they're right here [ __ ]
she said all right brad pitt you want to
know what's in the box i got it right
here i said
whoa yeah i was surprised and then she
essentially said
keep my name out of your mouths yeah
so unfortunately nate is gonna have to
edit david
as many times dave dave david actually
yeah can we do that
every time we say our name let's replace
it with it's
like a texas speech thing of like david
yeah david david
start starting now starting now right so
name
no longer in the mouth but it's fine
because um
well you know we'll get to that in a
second but i do have to read some of
these supportive messages from her fans
you mind if i bring them up yeah just
read them actually just read it
i got this one this one was great damn
bro you seem like a sad sack of [ __ ]
trying to
attack a female on new years
here's to you focusing on no one but
yourself in 2021
yeah [ __ ] yeah got me man [ __ ] yeah
you got me man [ __ ] dude 20 21 we're
putting the horse blinders on
and we're only thinking about us owned
man
got me here's another one
damn i was actually a fan i was rooting
for you stop
bullying someone who's already been
bullied relentlessly
listen man it's not my fault
also we weren't bullying i wasn't
bullying
we're not we're pissed because we don't
want to share number seven it doesn't
matter who it's with
it doesn't matter i know that she's been
bullied in the past
i mean i don't know maybe no but we
don't know we don't know if
she it's the internet who cares
well i mean a lot of drama went down
with her right yeah but
you know rightfully so that's what i'm
saying we don't know what they did was
[ __ ] crazy
yeah exactly and so yeah we can't what
are we saying we can't talk about that
no
we're number seven it doesn't matter who
it's with if we are after we
have to share that position i'm gonna
bring up the same sort of you know
uh kerfuffle wait i got i got one more
this one this one
absolutely killed me are you gonna shut
the [ __ ] up now
you know she did since she got the gifts
and you've been dragging her name
look [ __ ] she got the gifts they're
right there see the balancing rocks
clearly she's also number seven
only number sevens get balancing rocks
from spotify even i know that
reading these on new year's day i was
like
wow wow
this is only because of quarantine i
give them all a pass if
if there was no covid right now they
would they would not have even
wasted their time you don't think you
don't think that they're that dedicated
to the podcast she probably maybe has
some die-hard fans
yeah but she does no it couldn't happen
because it would have been somewhere
with like no reception
they would have tried right like they
would have seen her story the [ __ ]
guy is doing it
hold on and then he'd go into the
bathroom like some you know
bar in ohio and he'd be like you [ __ ]
way to attack a woman on it's not going
through dude
it's not going through what why does he
have no service
there's like a million people in one
place and the [ __ ] one tower next to
the bars is getting overloaded with
people uploading pictures to facebook
oh you mean he's like he's like in times
square
yeah but the ohio the ball's dropping
he's like hold on a second hold on yeah
hold on i know mom i just gotta [ __ ]
i gotta get this guy this guy is
bullying this [ __ ]
shut the [ __ ] up mom you don't get it
yeah
yeah so you know um and
i had a good chuckle over there but it's
fine guys because
you know we're not going to talk about
sofia anymore because
we're above that yeah literally we're
going above that
this year the goal is to get the pi the
podcast to number six
yeah we've been talking you know last
episode on the bonus if you heard that
or if you didn't
we talked a lot about resolutions goals
for
us business goals goals for the show
you know we have a new producer now luke
who's
on this call actually yeah at this
moment luke and
and kyle are now on the calls yes
and uh that's why i'm not yawning
because i'm afraid
i'm gonna get in trouble by one of them
if i [ __ ] yawn
swallow the [ __ ] cough drop yeah
um no we talked a lot a lot about goals
and uh what we want to achieve and i
think what we settled on
was the main one which is we're gonna
get we're gonna escape this drama
we're gonna be above it we're gonna take
the high road because we're shooting for
number six this year
now this is number six on spotify that's
our goal and
we need all of your help in achieving
that goal
justin bieber style you know if you got
if you got a grandma who is like you
know senile
doing dialysis and [ __ ] just like put
two skull candy
ear pods in here in her ears
and just run the podcast on loop what's
up guys welcome to say grandma you're
doing a service
yeah you know how you know by the way
this is
officially officially this is the year
of the six
yes officially just make that very clear
this is the year of the six
year of the six we're going for six
now listen if if if david wants to
challenge for six
then maybe we're not above this beef
maybe it continues but that's only if
david chooses to go with number six oh
that
no yeah we're not saying we're above any
beef we're saying we're above
this beef because this is number seven
yeah we're shooting for six if anyone
wants to come for six
then absolutely it's going to be a war
if you want to go for five
i mean that's fine yeah we'll go for it
we're not that good
taking a high road we're not five
caliber yet we're still
we're almost six caliber i'd say we
believe we're six
yes for sure i think that um in the same
vein as the grandma thing you know how
people play
beethoven and you know some nice
composers for their
for their fetus for their unborn fetus
gain a little bit of culture in the womb
i'd say go ahead and play tmg what's up
guys welcome to the
yeah not the music play the podcast loud
yeah into your stomach
yeah direct actually do it actually take
one of your air pods and put it in your
belly button
swallow it swallow the left one and put
the right one
in your belly button yeah so then you
know
when it consumes one of the ear buds
and then it's like you know actually in
your fetus's stomach and then the
the sound waves are going through
between the belly button and inside
their stomach you're going to get the
whole it's like going to embody the
whole thing
yeah they'll be in and around they'll be
surrounded by the podcast
and that way when he's born he or she
they'll just come out puking and
[ __ ] at the same time yeah
yeah and moaning
[Laughter]
he's picturing a fetus puking and
[ __ ]
coming out of the womb bro through the
first word
he looks like he's about to say
something what's it gonna mean
that's [ __ ] up that is so [ __ ] up
no it's a really messed up joke if you
think about it it is but it's not
because that's just how serious we are
about that's general number six that's
that's why no one
no that's why no one streamed yummy
because justin was too
he was too like soft touch about it if
he was going to make those requests he
should have gone
all the way yeah play this for your
newborn fetus
you